Apple's M2 lineup of Max was good but
honestly not great they're missing a
little something that we've been
obsessing over for just about the last
year and that's three nanometer chip
technology from the most important place
in the world a little island named
Taiwan and if you don't understand why
it's so important you will by the end of
this video as I'll be talking about the
performance of the M3 M3 Pro and M3 Max
chips but first I've got to go through
some brand new updates in terms of when
each and every M3 Mac will get released
like the M3 MacBook Air the high-end
MacBook Pros the Max studio Mac minis
Mac Pro and maybe even the iMac Pro now
what you absolutely need to understand
first is that these three nanometer
chips from tsmc are gonna use brand new
technology on new three nanometer nodes
that are going to be very expensive
about 25 more expensive than the current
into five nanometer notes and because of
that tsmc has been having some serious
yield issues which essentially means how
many of the actual three nanometer chips
or Wafers are going to pass inspection
and how many they will simply toss out
with the most recent update only about
55 percent of the Wafers were passing
inspection which is actually quite
terrible because Apple needs enough
yield for both the a17 chips and M3 and
because of that there was speculation
that Apple could delay the release of
the M3 chip to next year in the spring
and then that would delay the entire M3
Mac lineup even further however it's
looking like that actually won't be the
case so let's jump into those new leaks
a couple of weeks back Mark Grumman
reported that apple is planning an event
for October to release some new products
which are most likely going to be the
first range of M3 Max including
potentially the M3 MacBook air the
MacBook Pro and M3 iMac and even better
we got another report from digit times
that Apple Was preparing to launch a new
Macbook Pro with a three nanometer chip
later this year which is of course the
M3 chip which solidifies Mark German's
report now at first I had a hard time
believing this because of all of the
yield issues which meant apple would
have a very low supply of chips this
fall but then we received another very
important update that changed everything
apparently Apple's brand new 15-inch
MacBook Air didn't do nearly as well as
Apple thought it would in terms of
launch sales now personally I thought
that this would be the best-selling
MacBook right out of the gate because of
the large 15-inch display combined with
a super thin design and killer 12.99
price tag which was even less expensive
than my own estimates but no the
shipment volume in July was 50 percent
lower then originally estimated why well
because the entire laptop Market is
suffering right now due to a downturn in
the economy and other factors so this
got me thinking what if the low yields
for Apple's 3 nanometer a17 and M3 chips
won't even matter because the demand for
laptops right now isn't nearly as high
as it was before so the low Supply would
be matched with lower demand plus if you
think about it Apple made the smart move
of only putting the latest Apple silicon
chips into the pro model iPhones so the
new iPhone 15 and 15 plus will continue
to use the five nanometer a16 champ so
because of those reasons I actually
think that Apple can pull it off and
release the first M3 Max this fall after
the launch of the iPhone 15 lineup and
that's apparently what Apple suppliers
are preparing for right now including
Apple's partnering semiconductor
back-end houses a and test interface
Specialists according to a brand new
report and honestly a launch this fall
makes perfect sense since it would be
about 1.5 years after the launch of the
M2 Chip and that was actually launched
1.5 years after the M1 so the timelines
match up perfectly now keep in mind we
also had the leak from Mark German back
in March that Apple's new M3 iMac was
nearing final development and could
launch as soon as later this year so we
could potentially have all of the first
M3 Max at the same time in October
including the 13-inch M3 MacBook Air the
13-inch M3 MacBook Pro and the 24 inch
M3 iMac however I think it'll be wise
for Apple to delay the iMac until March
or April of next year alongside the
release of the M3 iPad Pro so that the
attention is a bit split up which is
exactly what they did with the first M1
iMac when they released it about six
months after the very first M1 Max now I
know you're gonna ask about the 15-inch
MacBook Air and if that 2 is getting the
M3 chip but it honestly don't think it's
gonna get updated until later next year
but with that said let's jump into the
rest of the M3 Mac lineup starting with
the maps I'll be packing the M3 Pro and
M3 Max chips Mark German just gave us
another big update last Sunday
mentioning that the new 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pros will probably launch by the
middle of 2024 at the latest which would
be around one and a half years after the
M2 Pro and Max chips launched in January
so it makes perfect sense and then he
also mentioned the Mac Mini with M3 and
M3 Pro chips which he says won't get
released until late 2024 at the earliest
which means they'll launch after the
high-end MacBook Pro but in my opinion
they could easily launch at the same
time since they're two separate product
markets now thankfully Mark German also
confirmed that apple is working on a
brand new iMac with a larger than 30
inch display but it's still in early
development right now so it likely won't
launch until the fall of 2024 or maybe
even the spring of
2025. and finally we have the Mac Studio
and Mac Pro and I believe that these
could both launch around either the fall
of 2024 or potentially all the way up to
the summer of 2025 but at this point
it's really hard to guess and now with
those release dates out of the way we
can move into the performance part of
this video Jason cross from Mac world
put together some M3 chip lineup
performance estimates and while they're
on the conservative side they actually
do make sense because they match up with
recent leaks from Tech Reeve on Twitter
Twitter who claims the M3 chip won't be
as fast as he previously thought due to
Apple toning it down according to Jason
the M3 chip should sit at around 28 73
points and geekman's 6.1's single core
test which is a decent jump over the M2
with the M3 Max being a bit faster at
2988 and then moving on to the
multi-core test we're seeing the M3 chip
score just over 11 000 points which puts
it a decent bit ahead of the M2 and
still even slower than the bend at 10
core M2 Pro champ now in my opinion I
personally believe apple is going to be
giving the M3 chip a bigger performance
jump in multi-core potentially even
outperforming the bend M2 Pro by just a
little bit but of course my personal
estimations were based on an older
leaked a17 chip Benchmark which may not
be valid anymore and then of course we
have the M3 match ship estimate which
sits at around sixteen thousand five
hundred points which is actually almost
as fast as the M1 Ultra chip and once
again I honestly feel like apple is
going to be giving us a bigger
performance boost than this I feel like
the M3 Max should be scoring closer to
18 or 19 000 points with the new three
nanometer chip technology since it's
going to be a big technical jump over
the five nanometer chips but keep in
mind that the performance numbers won't
be everything and the big impressive
feat of these three nanometer chips will
actually be the performance per watt or
the ability to stay cool and use less
power while hitting these performance
numbers so we should see an increase in
battery life as well and that's what's
really exciting so with that said
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did click that Circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out one of those
two videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
foreign